all right so thanks for coming everybody
um um I was um wanted to give you a talk
about some of the stuff that I do uh to
leverage uh llms for text agation and
what I do topic modeling uh I let a bit
about myself uh my name is arel Gino I
work for a company called Athena Health
uh here in Austin Texas uh I work
specifically for an app called oces app
that doctors and clinicians use to look
up uh medical information uh drug
diseases and conditions uh and the
number one medical app uh in the US and
I also teach a class at the University
of Texas at Austin the mome School of
Business uh through in coordination with
two edx and it's a data analytics boot
camp uh that I teach uh and which
students come and learn about the
analytics python JavaScript uh SQL Tavo
and we do a little bit of machine
learning uh but I'm a my my role in
Athena hell is an a AI uh machine
learning engineer uh and I I've been
doing a for about five years and I've
been doing um deex Stu for about more
than 20 25 years so um I wanted to talk
to you about some of the stuff that I do
and kind of give you an idea of how I
leverage uh data um and first of all
what is data augmentation and data
augmentation refers to artificially
generating new data from existing data
in order to expand the size and improve
the quality of the data set so he
creates plausible new data uh that uh
you can use and generate instead of
having to collect data from scratch and
some some common methods of of of data
vation uh specifically for computer
vision include like random crops or
flips or rotations uh and stuff like you
see here which is maybe you have an
original image and then you change the
texture you change the color uh you
change the edges of it and then you do
maybe a selan map which just kind of
marking it and then again flip and
rotate uh and for natural language
processing tasks uh augmented data might
be generated through either paraphrasing
something saying it in another way
random insertions of text uh synonym
replacement uh or leveraging train large
language models which I show you in a in
in a in a moment um but overall data
amation en enables you to uh uh use
train machine learning models with more
robust data and more diverse data than
you started with um and this reduces
overfeeding uh improves generalization
and also building a higher performing
model and in in scenarios where you
don't have enough data uh and and this
is something has become uh instrumental
for our my company and myself to be able
to do uh the stuff that we
do so what is topic modeling so this is
talk is about how do we leverage llm and
and and to augment data for topic
modeling and topic modeling it's an
unsupervised machine learning technique
that that can be used to identify topics
uh and themes in a large text carpus and
the key idea behind this topic modeling
is that documents consist of multiple
topics in different proportions where
each topic represent a cluster of of
awards that that frequently occur
together so when performing topic
modeling uh this algorithm algorithms
analyze uh word current patterns within
documents which allow you to discover uh
semanic structures and extract um
meaningful topics so you're looking at a
cpose of of of text and you can stract
uh categories and topics based on this
thing um that you do and as you can see
in the picture you start with topic
modeling in one way and you create
topics based on this uh documentation
that you have and again it could be used
to kind of categorize and cluster
different parts of your documents and
and you come up with topics that
represent uh those those
documents and the problem we're trying
to solve is how do we solve insufficient
uh insufficient data and superise models
require large amounts of label training
data like I said so you may have a small
sof set of of of data or data you need
to enhance to be able
to Leverage The supervised models to
train them um and for many task in the
mains quality training data is car so
you don't have enough of it um and even
if you if you have enough of it you
might not be the quality that you need
and this limits model accuracy and
generalization so again model when
you're training a model it's kind of
hard to um to get a good grasp of gener
iing uh on your on your context because
you don't have enough data so one of the
solutions that I uh I've done is is
basically using a large language models
um to augment data generation so first I
collect a initial SE of data set from my
NLP task it could be sentiment analysis
could be categorization it could be
topic modeling so I collect small uh
initial seed
uh I fit the samples uh uh with prompts
from this data set uh into the llm in a
way that will augment my uh training
data and then I filter Genera samples to
remove low quality samples so fitting
the uh my C data into LM get the stuff
out and filter them out just to make
sure that I have quality data and then I
add the augmented data to uh to my
original training Set uh and this this
is a pattern that I follow in some of
stuff that I do day today and it's been
really useful in me to get better
results uh and this is an example that I
that I created just for for the
presentation in which I do have a
collect initial seed uh data set for an
NLP test let's say this is sentiment
analysis and this is a hugin facee uh
tweet evaluation um data and the Tweet
eval data set contains emojis contain a
bunch of stuff and one of them uh is
emotions which basically have uh a
training data has a tweet and it has a
label on it that you have and I
apologize for the for the some of the
words that are showing up but I just
randomly selected from from what that
was um and the Second Step that I said I
feed the sample prompts from the data
set back into the llm to generate a main
output so we start with a um a mation
prompt in which you are have a writer
that takes sentences and replaces with
the synonyms uh but keep the sentiment
of the original sentences so if you
can't think of any synony
just return the same sentence and this
is one of those things that um is really
useful to be able to leverage
llm uh in order for me to do uh a m data
so again I take the the original text
which are the tweets that you saw I add
this prompt and say hey give me
something similar um but uh with a
different maybe change synonyms or
change something in it so I can use it
as train data and I do that into a large
language model uh that uh that allows me
to uh then get more augmented data uh
and the next step that I that I put on
on the previous slide is to filter uh
this generated data for uh quality and
in in this case some of the stuff that
even got generated one of the first
things I did was to say okay give me the
original tweet uh augmented with new
data but check to make sure that the new
augmented data has the same sentiment um
than the other one and even though the
llm um might generate stuff that it's uh
it's it's you know accurate and and we
as humans can identify the same meaning
you have to make sure that the data that
you have is quality because in this case
about 15% of the of the use cases were
not the same as the original um
sentiment and and again so the next step
would be to filter those out um and then
once we have that then we have uh
augmented data that we can see and we
can use for training or or for whatever
we using it uh and again we started with
a a simple text that has original
tweet and then we augmented it uh with
llm and basically asking through a prom
a you a useful um writer I'm going to
give you a text just give me the same
thing and you maybe change synonyms and
I only use synonyms for this example but
you can do things like change you know
paraphrase it or will say another way uh
but indicating in the prompt not to
change the sentiment and again here
again if you read this this thing Happy
Birthday J birthday and things like that
it's pretty much the same meaning from a
from a human understanding perspective
and the sentiment that it generated is
the same so again this is the um the
important part of the code uh so let me
let me show to you in
code yeah so I do created I'm Happ happy
to provide this uh uh to you guys just
send me a message and I'll I'll send you
the link to my repa but basically I
started by getting the data and again
just uh tweet Evol data set and I'm
using the emotion parts of it there a
bunch of them uh and I'm using a subet
of them and this data set has something
like a down payment no problems has a
tweet uh and it has a label uh in this
case uh the label is optimism I think
here over here uh and I only keep 300
tweet just for for this exercise uh on
this thing and again I have a text oral
text and I have a label in it uh the
next thing I did I added a column on the
sentiment to be able to uh compare me
when I was generating the llm uh Text
data so I can see it in a way that that
makes sense uh this is the distribution
of the sentiments the one thing I I've
didn't do in the code that could be part
of your augmenting the data is to make
sure the data I balance in this case we
have a lot of anger and a lot of Joy or
optimism uh again those are tweets so
it's kind of makes sense uh but one of
the things I would recommend you doing
if you're doing this technique is
basically make sure your data is
balanced and and I'll do that in in
another exercise but uh for now I just
load of the classifier just to kind of
say Okay classify these tweets so I can
compare them against the ones that get
generated uh and again you I created a
prom that says you're a helpful writer
that takes a sentence replace it with
synonyms and give me the same keep the
same sentiment and this part is as
critical because U the llm will know
that what you're trying to do is okay
just change the phing for new data but
keep the sentiment so so when I train it
it
basically same results and again you
know war is a down payment for uh you
may never have and then uh the llm uh
generator and I'm using Penny Ice uh for
this but you can use many other uh
anxiety serves as an initial investment
and a potential issue that may never
come to frin so I mean it's similar to
what the original intend was um but the
uh it is it's creating brand new data
that you can use for tring and again the
classifier of the original Tex was uh
number two optimism and the classifier
for the new tax generated is score and
this is the part that uh again you you
have to check that the quality of your
llm generary data makes sense all right
so basically I want to show you this uh
uh I generate the text the augmented
text in the other hand and then I I I
make sure that um the data I created you
know I only use the stuff that is uh
quality wise matches the original
intent so this is simple example I want
to show you from using uh tweet data uh
I'm going to show you now uh how I use
it for topic modeling which is kind of
like the um the main idea and again I
just want to give you an idea of this is
how you can use a l language mod model
to be able to generate synthetic data
that you can use for uh training in D
that was more for classification but
this one is more for topic
modeling and topic modeling like I said
is basically the ability to uh assign
keywords to a specific the document so
you can classify them in clusters and I
use data from open fot facts which is
has about about 2.3 million products
from about 182 countries uh the data is
open and it's fre use uh they do give
you either a CSV or they give you a
a DB database um the step that I
do here in this process that I'll show
you the code uh I extract all the data I
first I basically downloaded put it into
database I extract the data I
remove common keywords I use openis
again to generate synthetic data out of
my LM and I'm using the basic you know
3.5 uh turbo for this and then I create
a reer
richer expression richer sentences of
what the product what the um the food uh
it's it's showing you and then I used uh
word topic which is a um way for you to
do training a model to come up with a um
categories topics within this this
text so let me go
here so I use open Foods uh Ty toing uh
and I use LM to expand into Rich
synthetic data to generate uh uh
paragraphs describing products uses and
let
me few steps here but the first step
that I do is to start with most uh C
data set just like I did for the tweets
um with the products Nam and categories
that have I clean that up a little bit
my next step is to use LM to expand and
to reach synthetic data so I start with
something that is might not be as clear
from a quality perspective but through
an nlm i come up with this rich and uh
really well explained data that is based
on my original data and then I train out
topic model and then I cluster I I use
bir topic to Cluster the descriptions to
discover product groups and Trends and
this is something we're doing similarly
in my uh work Health uh company for some
of the backend search and recommendation
systems that we have so we have a small
sub set of data that we enrich for
clustering and then we use it for um
recommendations in the back end but this
one is is using the up foods of fact
data
set uh so I start with a small data set
and again the data has about uh 6,000
columns so it's a bunch of data that you
get from open source some of them is
incomplete some of them is not uh there
and some of them have a known stuff so
the idea for leveraging llm is basically
how do you go from having data set that
might not be as rich and as complete um
to something that makes sense for a
clost Rak and again this is kind of like
uh I I collect the ra data pandas data
frame I just get the row convert that
into a dictionary and a dictionary might
look something like this which has a uh
again labels a language and some uh
some something about ingredients and
some Creator and some brand so it's all
this like not really concise and kind of
all over the place information that I
get so I get this information and then I
use use uh another prompt to explain to
reach synthetic data and again I
generate paragraphs describing the
products in a way that has more quality
than the original data that we have and
in my PR that I use and I'll show to you
in one second uh you are a helpful text
creator that takes incomplete
information about a food product and
create a well-written explanation of
what you're giving it again something
that is not as complete and I kind of
give an example of of this and I say
something like you might giving a
product say product name and some some
name in it might become unimited might
not and one of the one of the the the
main takeways from this when you're
prompting your llms is make sure that
you also tell it what not to do when you
couldn't find information uh and this is
something that I found um because
sometimes if you don't tell it if you
don't know the
answer you know it will give you like
random stuff uh code or like you will go
hallucina that not there so I basically
specify specify that if you don't can't
create the information just write no
information from because this part you
will use it for uh again for being able
to uh signal uh and filter the quality
of your data right and there there are
other prompting techniques you can use
in in context learning um you know give
an examples shadb prompting only a few
examples you give it to as well or or
chain of top prompting which again you
going to go step by step um in this case
I kept it simple and it was good enough
for what I wanted it to do
so once I have created my uh data my
data set my my I I I look through filter
for anything that's not correct and I
look at the Quality and I feel that it's
you know good enough I then use bir
topic for uh the training and the cool
thing about B topic is that it's it's
kind of like a way for you to U do
multiple steps on training this model to
give you topics uh and each one of these
components you can change um so the
first thing you do is the vector session
of your text so you put in your base
data you put into an LM the LM gives you
a synthetic richer quality data and then
you create embeddings uh uh which
basically is representation in a vector
space that allow the the U the model to
be able to Cluster them better so that's
the first step you have and uh you can
do as bird you can do a bunch of other
you can use your model that you have uh
your language model to do the embeddings
um to be able to do this thing the next
that you have to do is uh do a
dimensionality reduction so you have
embeddings that going be 10,000 or 700
length um and you can use those out of
the box but but the the larger your
embeddings are the harder it is for you
to Clash of them so the first thing you
should is make it smaller without losing
some of the uh representations that it
come with and that's where umap uh comes
in and then we do a clustering of those
things so there's something called HB
scan which is similar to K means but
it's more for spatial clustering uh K
means is more like a uh it's simpler
than than HTV scan HB scan is great for
things that might not be as related as
uh I think and again text you know you
have this dimensions in the deor space
that might not be as uh easy to Cluster
but HB scan does a good uh it's an
algorithm that you can use to be able to
close them better uh and then the last
part of where topic that he does uh you
talken everything and do tfid which is
basically cutting keywords uh in a way
that um you match uh keywords that are
related so the good thing about topic is
each one of the steps you can swap by
something else you want use K means you
can use means you want to if you don't
want to use a con vectorizer you can get
it off and you can just use a TF ID so
it's really modularized in a way that
it's kind of easy to use and that's what
I like it uh and we use it for um for
more topic modeling uh and the last
thing you do is just basically come up
with a topic so this is an example of
bird topic giving you clusters and
descriptions to the Discover groups of
Trends and again this is for my um up
food data set and you can see that the
first topic has cheese and dairy and
milk and creamy so you kind of determine
that this are related in a way that you
know makes sense uh uh chicken tender
meal meat options so again they kind of
related and again these are the the bird
topic uh looking at your data set and
automatically uh
coming up with this topic is based on
the embeddings and based on the
presentation that it does and all the
step that it does and this is the output
and you can use this for either search a
recommendation or some other downst
Stacks that you use it but again it's
really powerful thing technique to be
able to go from data that is not um that
well written you know data to enhancing
it with llm and then creating a clusters
using our topic so let me show you what
that looks like this in code
I know we have a few minutes left but
let me show you to
you
um
here back second
screen and again the first thing I do is
to get the data from up f facts and I
guess I have my local mongodb database I
extract data I filter it for common
keywords that I know may not add to the
quality of data set I put put it through
open AI the llm to leverage that part of
LM to create text uh and then I I I come
up with a f a product definitions and I
do topic moding for that uh and an
example of this thing so this is like a
a a record that has information and
again 6,000 columns you get for each
record which is a lot and the first
thing I do is convert this thing into
text that make sense text that are human
readable so I go from having all the
6,000 columns into extracting things
that um I know could be very minimum for
us to understand and I also eliminate
things like test uh web full uh calories
and things that I know that will be
repeated across my test Set uh this is
an example of a record that uh comes out
of just the raw data that I have again
just eliminating simple stuff and then
you have countries and categories and
you know nutrient and again the good
thing is it's a really rich data set the
bad thing is is not that complete um but
out of this I I CL out the common
keyword values so I only end up with
something like this so each one of these
things represents a record um that is
the r data and and this is what I feed
to the llm this is what I say hey this
this thing is called PR name is called
Virginia Bram these are the keywords
that it has in it this is some owner
that it has and then I ask the um llm to
generate test uh text on that again I my
prompt and my uh big take away the prom
you know make sure that you are as
specific as possible if you can give it
examples give it an example to the
prompts uh but also tell it tell the
prompt tell the lamp what you want if
not information on this is kind of key
to be able to filter out later your
stuff um and and this is again example
of going from something like this which
has a simple uh really
incomplete uh information to coming up
with something that says okay very value
a protocol and describes in detail um
the stuff that this product is about so
this is the this is the using the llm to
generate quality synthetic data and
again this is really good for a topic
modeling because you are the end product
is just basically coming with the
Clusters not anything anything else and
it's really useful because the llm uh uh
getting U simple data like this is able
to uh to generate u a really cool
Des it for this and then I I save it
into local database I and I basically
just use it for my be topic and the B
topic code I'll show it to you also
again I read the data and this is the
data that we have we have a simple text
in one end which again is limited is
based on my R data set it's based on me
cleaning some of the stuff uh and it
comes up with a a generated uh
quality data that is more with better
quality than where you started and it's
pretty good at describing the product of
you know this this product is called the
valy and kind of describing what it is a
beverage this thing about cheeses and
creamy it's a creamy like spreadable
cheese and again this is kind of like
the magic and like the big way is like
you can use an llm to start with simple
n scripture data to something that is
really useful and again I cling a little
bit the filter the data that is not you
know if if if the LM didn't find any
information I filled that out um and
again I just just a sample of some of
that uh that that I generated with the
training Set uh I build the ter the
birth topic model the umap section and
you can tweak some of the values the
neighborhood and the components for it I
do the stb scan step which again it ises
the clustering side of it I do the EMB
better step which is the bets um and
then I can basically create my bird
topic with all the stuffff that I
created had a conver Riser and and I do
like a repetition model to kind of fine
tune it at the end and I just train it
and it's you know train BR my
model and uh one of the things that I I
use for Ministry and performance topic I
use something called coherence and
diversity and coherence is basically how
how how inter interpretable the keywords
are how do they make sense that's
basically coherence measures and the
diversities how diverse are the keywords
this keywords being repeated all over
the place so the two scores to keep in
mind is coherence score the higher the
better and diversity again the higher
the better and again for this Stu here
uh out of the box just TW in a few
parameters by using llm generary data I
got a coherence score 0.943 which pretty
good you know the maximum is one uh it's
pretty telling you that um this topic
modeling that I created it was really uh
good at doing topic modeling because of
the that I fed and just again to give
you an idea the other one and I giv you
this is map and again this is btop I
give you you clusters and you can look
at it in a map and you can see the
actual topics each one of them in this
kind of cool way to do it and again
chicken tender meal meat you can kind of
see related and how it tells you how
probability of that being the case for
the topic you can also cluster your
topics in a way that you can see
everything in one place um and I just
got to show you real quick training
training the same model but not using
synthetic data and again just using the
r data you saw the simple product name
maybe C labels that incomplet
data and it gives you it gives you
something but some of the stuff is not
that that well represented because again
you don't have enough information for
the topic modeler some of the stuff is
not that bad but some of the stuff like
product name product name product name
that doesn't really make sense for a
topic
perspective and again you can see the
map here but the the score I didn't put
it here but the score here on my next
slide just to show you is will just very
quickly interrupt you uh thank you so
thank you so much it's extremely
extremely uh like useful and very know
knowledgeable you have a a lot of
information here and present that
greatly that's our uh last talk for
today so we have some extra time so uh
please feel free uh to use about like
next 15 minutes or so yeah absolutely
and again this is the uh the modeling
metrics that I came up with and again
the coherence is much better with
synthetic data than without synthetic
data um and again it's a way for me to
want to show you how you can leverage
llms to uh be able to get better quality
data for uh topic modeling all right any
questions
all right well hopefully you found it
useful uh I'm happy to share the slides
later on Camila let me know how and
happy to share the code as well but
thank you for for the
opportunity yeah thank you for the for
this actually I have one one one
question like about the um production
production use of that like uh is it
something which um yeah which which you
are using in in your work or you know
like how people are using that yeah so
this this is something we use in my own
company in the backend um and we use it
to classify some of the documents that
we have in the back end and we we use
this process to augment augmented data
set to be able to build a better
recommender uh and we have a
recommendation system in the back end
that uses a bunch of data set data
points from our data set and one of
those data points is topic modeling so
the categories that we have for the
topics and instead of us or even having
to label it by hand we feeding into a
system that the output of it are topics
that then get uh used in a recommender
system in the back
end oh wonderful yeah it's always uh
really cool to see that in like how
companies are really using that and I
believe that we'll have that more and
more um in the future uh I see some some
question on the on the chat
okay how do you convince the customers
to use the models by using syn data that
might not represent
real population data and um introduce
some
biases yeah that is a good question and
that is one of the steps that I kind of
went really fast on it like filtering
the you know the one step that you have
to make sure you you have is the quality
of the data set so once you generate
your synthetic data you have to have
measures in place to make sure that the
quality of it is is you know it's it's
legit and it works in the Tweet example
I basically say you know does it match
the original sentiment that's like the
the simplest thing you can do for for
quality in our own system we do have
checks and balances in the back end we
have models that detect when a Tex that
is generated it's not coherent or it
doesn't represent the medical stuff that
we trying to do and again our use case
we don't none none of our data sets that
we use synthetically are are for end use
we use it for internal recommendation
systems which you know which they become
better um but yeah we you have to have a
bunch of uh if you're going to use this
data set for um anything
related if you for that for training
data you have to make sure that uh you
have a few steps of quality control and
you know inbalance data and bias data
for sure uh on it so yeah good
question uh wonderful thank you for this
question thank you for the answer as
well and technically one one information
for for your Ariel in terms of the
slides uh we'll be collecting slides on
the Google Drive so I will send you the
link uh for the Google Drive and it
would be great if you could just upload
that there uh the recording from uh from
the uh from the stock and from other
talks and workshops will be we'll start
working on that um next week and you
will get the information when that will
be published perhaps it will be
published on the pay data YouTube
channel and um yeah do we have
oh yes we have another question yeah why
why is ATV scan over DV scanner or C in
clustering um yeah SC be more more
efficient for L larger data sets uh I
just a great question the problem the K
means is that is not really good with
spatial data and data that is really
vectorized in a way that is have this
huge dimensionality so k k me is great
for like lower dimensionality uh systems
H scan is for for things that I might
not be um um that might have a lot of
noise in it and that's why ATB scan is
but but again bir topic allows you to
swap some of the stuff that you have you
want to use K for clustering you can no
problem uh and this is part of the this
is the Des science of of power of their
signs right you get to play with that um
yeah good
question uh wonderful okay so do we have
any other question
yes we have how do we present bias and
unfairness in uh in this cases in in
this llm
systems yeah and again this is one of
those things that is really um a topic
for a longer discussion a longer
presentation but the quality step the
filtering step is really important
depending on the downstream TX that you
have right and I think that if your data
is biased from the get-go you'll
synthetic that will be bias as well so
that's one of those things about um
using model that if if you did a from
the beginning is bias you have to have
uh checks in pled you have to have
quality steps to be able to prevent that
and again you can do perplexity you can
do other other scores to be able to
measure how well it represents your data
set but uh it is one of the challenges
you do you know some of the stuff that I
think on um the AI side and data science
side is using models to
to basically detect stuff like that the
models that are trained just to detect
anything on the data set that are bias
or the imbalance and then using those as
a filtering step before you can do uh
you can reuse any of the synthetic data
it's a good
question uh in terms of bias ni um the
term many like check checklist uh
created for example for from Microsoft
and from from other companies uh also
some uh research um entities also create
that kind of check L which helps with AI
on the yeah on the um like starting
through with with with data everything
starts with data uh do you are you
familiar with like uh do you maybe have
your own checklist that's my follow-up
question for you Ariel so yeah we like
we have techniques but not for the bias
side of it we have techniques for the
quality side of it which is again when
we generate data uh we need to make sure
that is appropriate and specific for
what we are
doing uh and again we do have like a
couple of steps that we do like medical
checks like hey this generator let's say
I'm generating data for a specific
Tylenol and I say give me a synthetic
data for U The Scribe tyl anybody
something like hey T is great for
headaches or you know pain medicine so
we have keywords that we extract from
the synthetic data to kind of signal the
quality and kind of like measure that um
but yeah that's that's how we use we
have steps for that for as medical
specific not not for bias